Directly with the people who
build the platform. Um, so we
are involved in a lot of doing,
a lot of the customer testing.
We'll collate the feedback and
then sort of pass it back to the
team. So don't feel like you're
gonna offend us. Be as honest as
you can please and think out
loud. So if something alarms you
at first instance, don't keep
quiet about it to let us know
that they're the sort of things
that we want to know. On the
other hand, if something looks
really good and you know you
like the progress that we've
made, but also like to know
about that, so just be
completely honest, you won't.
Your own offenders? Um, cool.
Without further ado, I will hand
it over to Magda who will take
you through the platform.
Great. Thanks. Thank you. So
sorry, just before you start,
I'll just put my video off so
it's less distracting when
you're showing the platform.
Sure, I'll do the same on my
side because it gives me a
little more screen space.
OK. Well, I'll follow them.
OK, perfect. So Bernard, I
understand that you've already
done testing with us previously.
So um, what I'm going to do
today is to show you the
differences between what
happened between when we when
you spoke to us last time and
now. But do please do ask
questions, please raise anything
that you, unless you want me to
to go through the whole thing if
you if you would like a
refresher as well up to up to
you.
So I have to say.
Maybe a refresh is not a bad
idea and the reason I have to
say the reason for that is for
the last two months I've been so
busy on other things that I
haven't actually entered
evaluate, I think well twice I
think, but for very specific
things rather than a general
look. Understood. OK, So what
you can see here is the landing
page of our new platform. Some
of those things are still
placeholders because platform is
still under construction. But
this, this should give you an
idea what we are thinking about
in terms of what.
What would be useful for
yourself when you when you log
into to see so you will be able
to click through your quick
links that will take you to
specific specific areas, you
will have a summary of latest
news and then this is new. I
don't think this was the this
was the actual build thing last
time when you were testing. So
at the moment you are able to
already access your saved
reports that you have created in
this new platform.
And then whenever you are on a
different page than the landing
page, you also are going to be
able to access them through this
little icon on the top OK.
Have access to the report it
just through a different
mechanism. That was all yes,
yes. So do you find this how do
you think about? What do you
think about this? Because at the
moment when you log into
evaluate, you have to access
your reports via. It takes you
to a specific page where you
have all of your reports.
That that's my understanding. So
in here. Yeah. Yeah. So I think
that's fine. I think the the one
thing that I've that you've
gotta have is you've got to
limit the number of reports and
just say, OK, you can Scroll
down as you've got on the news,
you have the Scroll down
because.
One of the things that also is
important is sometimes those
reports need to be well. I need
to update some of these specs of
the report.
And so for instance, when I've
done a. This is just a FYI, I'm
really going off topic here. So
I I I have I update them once in
a while just to make sure that
they're still current. That's
all.
OK. Useful to have there. That's
a quick overview, yeah.
Right. Well, thank you. That's
really useful feedback.
So if you wanted to add another
report to your saved reports,
you can create a new one from
scratch. So let's go through
this button here and then you've
got. At the moment it's just a
few starting points here, but
obviously that list is going to
get longer as we build the
platform. So as an example,
let's go through indications,
generate report.
And you and at the moment you
have the, um, options to um.
You've got your report on the on
the full screen as well as when
you go to manage columns. You
can add or remove your columns
here which is also available on
the full screen. I think last
time when you did testing with
us it was a smaller window. So
we've made that larger to to
make sure that all of these are
are visible. So when you're
looking at indications, are you
not going, I mean you give the
opportunity of going direct to
the indication and just
wondering whether.
You had the opportunity of going
through the tree, if you will.
That is to say, are we splitting
it by disease area?
Or.
Mode of action or which other
method I I think it looks like
indication but I.
But there's so many indications
in in medicine that it's useful
to sometimes maybe try and split
them into main therapeutic areas
such as respiratory,
cardiovascular.
Oncology and so on.
Yes. So let me just, uh, if I
understand this correctly. So
this is the, umm, this is the
default, um kind of setup for
this report for indications
reports. So you can see there
are three levels from our
indications 33IN evaluate. So
you can go as high level As for
example, cancer or as low as
breast cancer, for example,
through solid tumours, which is
the indication level 2. So it's
really up to you how much.
Granularity you need in your
report.
That's great. OK. No, that's
fine. That's what we have now.
Right now. Yes. OK, that's fine.
OK. So it doesn't take you
directly to the bottom level.
No, no, no, it doesn't. It's
it's really up to you.
So, OK, so we've got our default
columns, um. And then in those
folders there are additional
data points that we can add to
our report. If we search here,
that search covers all of those
folders. But then also as you
expand each of them, you can
search for particular things
related to drugs or companies or
indications that we had those.
In. So let's go and add, let's
say market status. So then we
can.
Maybe we can have a look at.
Europe market status why not?
Because you did mention that you
you look at early stage
pipeline, we can then philtre it
further. So um, yeah. So you can
see it's at the bottom of the of
the report. That means it's
going to be our last column in
the report. But now you can also
drag and drop your columns to
reorder and what we've changed
recently is for you to be able
to see where this is going to
land by adding that that shade.
Kind of looking at that, it's
it's a little bit further.
And then you are also able to
remove your columns by clicking
through that red button here. So
before I hit apply changes to
see what the report looks like,
what do you? What do you think?
Bernard Bernard, what are your
thoughts about this?
So just need a little more
information. So what you have is
A and I'm guessing it's
somewhere below that I can't see
right now. If you Scroll down is
the.
There's a in the report that
also for instance the either
month or year values that it's
referring to and I don't see
that on this these columns as a.
Output. So when you're looking
at sales, for instance, the
report will give you all of
these, and they will concatenate
them of course, but they're
also.
And I don't see the of the
ranges from 2021 to 26, OK.
Yes, apologies. I should have
mentioned that this is where you
where you filtered, yeah.
Mm-hmm. OK. No, that's fine.
OK. And then also you have
options to change those um to
half yearly or quarterly as well
if you want to um?
Do that for your report. So
yeah, let's click apply changes
and just to um.
Just just wanted to highlight
that this is, this is still
being built, but when we are,
uh, when we are ready to
migrate, you yourself, your
colleagues and our other
customers, we are going to have
the same data on the new
platform. So the user experience
is going to be completely new
and transformed, but the data is
still the evaluate data. So if
you see something that doesn't
look right at the moment, that's
only because it's under
construction, but as we.
As we progress with the Umm
platform development, UM, I just
want to to make sure that that
you know that you know the data
is is still our data.
OK, so this is our report, um,
as you can see, we have, uh,
we've got our indications here.
So you've got your level 1-2 and
three and as you mentioned, we
can, we can.
We can select specific uh
specific levels. So what we have
recently done um is the is the
philtre options for those
columns. So you are able to sort
in the ascending or descending
order and also philtre. So you
can either search for a specific
or in this case indication or
you can.
Select a couple, um, or both and
then apply philtres.
And it's going to, it's going to
show you on your relevant data.
Another option here and as you
can see if you hover over that
little 3 dot menu pops up so you
so you can then select those
options. Another thing is you
can also pin your column to the
left, so now you can see that
indication level one is on your
left hand side, so as you scroll
your report to the right you can
still see which indication this
data refers to when you're
doing.
Filtering. Is this great? Is it
possible to also add in like
you've got the pin right? Is it
possible to also add in a symbol
to say you you're filtering
this?
Actually on the tab itself
rather than if you have the drop
down and the reason I say that
is because.
I know I've fallen into this
this myself, where you think,
oh, I've got the full report,
but actually it's I filtered
part of it.
Because of some other project
whatever and I didn't realise I
had a philtre on it.
Ohh, you mean when you when you
have filtered a column that it
actually indicates somewhere
here that it has been filtered
filtered.
Just to say OK, you've you've
you put a philtre on this
column.
Yes. OK. Yeah, I I understand.
Yeah. You did mention that you
sometimes go in and change your
programme parameters. So you
want to make you, you want to
know what's what. It has been
already filtered on. Understood.
Well, no, that it was filtered,
not what it was filtered on.
Because I to all I want to say
is let's say I've done the
report. I come back two days
later.
And I say, OK, this is the
report now when I saved it, I
saved it with some philtres. Now
I can't remember what those
philtres are always.
OK well that's that's the only
reason for having indication to
say yes this is this is what
you've got but you've you've
filtered on this column and then
you can have I can have a look
and see OK well what were the
philtres that I used otherwise
what happens is I have this
report and I forget that I
filtered on it and I come up
with the wrong.
Outcome.
Yes, understood. That's really
useful feedback. Thank you.
Umm.
OK. So we have shown you what's
the, UM, what are the options of
filtering text fields. So let's
go to a numerical field. So
let's, let's have a look at
sales. Can I philtre on sales?
Let's try another one.
Sales are indeed.
Looks like a little. Let me just
add something in here so I could
show you how we can um.
How we can potentially philtre
on numbers.
Um, let's let's do couple.
I'm sorry, I think apologies. I
think I need to refresh this. It
doesn't look like it's it's
responding correctly.
Let's try again.
Count.
Well, there you go. Let's add a
couple.
And then also a date field
because these philtres are also
different.
OK, apply changes.
All right, so now.
Let's go to the right um.
OK, so we've got our launch
date, so obviously same um, same
principle as sending the
sending, sorting um. And then
also with dates you can select a
specific range or a starting
point or a finish points as
well. So that's kind of a
replication of what you are able
to use to do with the date
fields in Excel.
And then with the counts.
The same thing with the umm with
ordering and then also you are
able to select it to philtre for
specific values in the specific
range, something that's less
than whatever and then equal to
and greater than. So different
options for.
For your numerical fields here
as well. Um, So what do you
think, Bernard? Do you think
this is useful?
Yes, because you can get rid.
OK, give a quick question to
make sure it's useful. Will it
you're filtering that out, but
will you? If it's sales for
instance, would you get a total
of everything?
Or would you just get the total
of what you see? That is to say,
let's say there are 20 rows. 10
rows are below 1000, let's say.
So that's 10,000 and the rest of
them is adds up to a significant
number. Would you get the total
number or just the filtered
number total?
So when you are filtering for
example, let's pretend these are
sales. So if you philtre on
specific, I don't know, let's
say less than less than 10,
let's just type it in.
Let's less than 10.
Because we have one which is 12.
That's why it's just easier to
see.
Yes. So you you've got your
individual um values here and
then the total which we haven't
built yet. It will only apply to
whatever the report is showing
like it does at the moment with
evaluate current platform.
OK, so once you're happy with
your report you can you have an
option here Bernard to either
save it and it will be visible
on your list on your landing
page or also available through
this button and then you can
also currently export your
report into CSV or Excel file.
And the report when you first
sign, say, I guess it will allow
you to modify. If it's an
existing report, either keep it
as the existing report or modify
the name.
That's coming up. So at the
moment the the name is the date
and also the your starting point
which shows indications earlier
and then in future you will be
able to to rename them as well,
OK, yes.
Cool. OK, so that's.
That's everything when it comes
to reports. Um, let me go to a
drugs page through the through
the menu here. All of these are
placeholders, but it should give
you an idea what we are thinking
in terms of grouping our data
and our offerings for for
yourself to to be able to
access. So a landing page for
drugs. So you have the.
Basic KPIs, high level KPIs at
the top of the page which shows
you what the market currently
looks like, range for your for
our consensus forecast and and
latest reported here and then
number of products within
evaluate universe by development
stage.
Then these are the UM
placeholders at the moment, but
um, these would be the umm the
most relevant, the the most
recent events and then a list of
your top top um.
How was the word
classifications, um MOA
indication, the umm, the the
most granular level that we have
and then therapeutic category
and then the also number of.
Of products per.
Specific classification.
Question, can I take you back
just a little bit and that is
for the selection of drugs,
where do you, you've got it
initiated with the initial
selection, where do you do that?
This is no unless this covers
everything. Hmm. Yes. So that's
this is, yeah, this is the very
top level for all drugs all over
the world.
Yes. Well, not all, all, all
over the evaluate, evaluate.
Well done. Yes, yes.
Yes. And then the idea of the UM
of this platform is going to be
is that you, you will be able to
click through, click through
those and they will take you to
more and more granular analysis.
So you will be then able to see
just phase one drugs and then
the relevant KPIs uh will also
be only for whatever you have
clicked through.
If that makes sense. So at the
bottom here we have um, we have
added a report as well and as
you can see, this is the.
This is the hyperlink that takes
you to.
A drug item page for a generic
name here that we have and then
also you can see what's the kind
of the the top information here,
which companies first launch um,
the branded name as well and
then some KPIs and your.
Your embedded report that you
are also able to either export,
save or edit as well if you
prefer to do so.
So would that be useful?
Yeah, that's a nice shortcut.
Ohh great. Thank you. Um. OK, so
on the left hand side we also
have um.
Sales. So um at the moment we've
got ohh actually let me go back
to can I actually can I yes go
back.
So this is by generic name
basically, right?
Do you have the same by?
Mode of action.
Because in in farmer you know we
have.
Um.
Many, maybe 10 or 15.
Generic named including brand
name.
Products but the but they're all
a little different but they're
all let's say EGFR inhibitors.
Hmm. And I just wondered whether
you go up to doing this, but
over.
The.
MOA.
Level.
Yes, so the index pages or for
uh for different classifications
are still under construction.
But it's really useful feedback
to know that MOA for example the
mechanism of action is something
that Bernard you would like to
see as a as a separate tab as
well.
Right.
OK. Well I think, I think that's
everything I wanted to show you
today. Um, we are still
developing. So just wanted to
run one thing past you and ask
if you, if we were thinking
about adding a chart to any of
the pages, drugs, drug summary
page or MOA like you say, like
you said Bernard would you would
you expect and would it be
useful for yourself to see a
chart here as well, so
certainly.
I think whenever you're talking
about sales, it's always useful
to have a chart because it's
just a visual impact.
OK. Yeah. Yeah, that's great. I
think then if you're looking at.
Products or generics. Sometimes
what you can see is number of
products in the field. Now this
is a little more.
Uh, let's see.
If you can do this this same
sales graph.
But split by.
And and you can't do it for all
drugs because it's it's it's not
ridiculous, but if you, if you
have it, let's say in a specific
MOA.
You can then split it by the
different constituent drugs.
In a new way, for instance, you
can't. And if you if you're
going to all drugs, what you
might be able to do and.
Is say, OK, all drugs, but this
is in the different therapeutic
areas. So in oncology in
cardiovascular I mean and then
but you've got to take the top.
Let's say 5 or something like
that and the rest of it's just
other. Otherwise it becomes an
impossible ridiculous.
Right, but I would yes, I'm, I'm
not by the way, I'm not
suggesting that at the moment,
but certainly when you take it.
When you take it down a couple
of levels it's always useful to
see, OK I've I've got in two
MOAS here which happened to
work. So in cardiovascular you
may have an ACE inhibitor and
and beta blockers and you may
want to look at the two together
because they both have the same
or similar indications, slightly
different but similar and they
sort of compete with each other.
So it's useful to see how their
evolution is going and and
projected.
OK, right understood. So and
also compared against each other
what the, what the forecast
looks like as well. So what I'm
showing you at the moment
Bernard is the is the is a
design it's not built in the
platform yet but there is also
one thing. So this is the an
indication um indication graph,
right. So OK and it's you can
see that these are different
different products here. Yeah,
yeah so the idea.
For the future is also, you
know, you should be able to
click through and go deeper into
the analysis as well. So is that
something that you would find
useful? Yes, yes. I mean we
don't use it that often, we use
it.
When we're doing a specific
analysis, and I would say
literally, maybe I'll do that
twice a year.
Myself, other people will do it
more often or less often
depending on what they need it,
but for instance, when we're
doing our strategic plans.
That's one of the things that we
do.
Right.
Understood. I mean, you know, it
doesn't matter how many times
they are, right? It's the the
easiest it is the better. So,
um, of course. No, that feedback
is really useful. Thank you.
I think that's everything that I
wanted to show you today Ankit.
Have I missed anything?
Um, I don't think so. So.
You've done the overview of the
platform. Let me just go through
the stuff that I heard.
Bernard, did you have any views
on the?
If you just um go back to the
index drugs index page, Magda,
did you have any views on the
events or the top three section?
Ohh, sorry, yeah, just the page
before this. So yeah, but not
just just in that middle bit
where you sort of see the events
and the top three section. Is
that something that would be
useful for you or would you sort
of scroll past that or what your
general thoughts on that so?
So this, this one, this
particular one where you've got
all drugs is actually not. I
mean it's it's.
It's something you put in a
report, but I know it's not
something that I'd actually use
ever.
So for instance, you have your
evaluate pharma report right
for.
And you and you, you take that
as a the PDF that you create.
Right. And so I do, I'd use the,
the, the figure that you use
where it places, OK, this is
oncology, this is cardiovascular
and so on, but I don't think I'd
go into depth.
Overall, so I wouldn't need.
I think this is great as a high
level, but as a high level
there's no point in trying to.
Cover everything.
And let me take that back.
At a high level, this is
something that I can share,
share to a shareholder at a
shareholder meeting.
This is of no.
Intrinsic use to me.
When I'm looking in a
therapeutic area.
Cool except you know to say Ohh
oncology is 20% of
cardiovascular or something like
that, but it's it's it's very
it's it's big picture, really
big picture but I wouldn't use
it as any detail for an analysis
per se. OK that makes sense. So
to make it have intrinsic value
to yourself not just the
shareholders, would you would it
be helpful once you philtre the
data in the table so once you've
filtered that all.
Your metrics will then update
according to your philtres.
Would that then make it more
valuable? That would be useful.
And at a lower level it's
useful. Fine for me because then
I can actually use that for
saying, well, how come you know
when I'm looking at then the
history, OK, how come they've
done XY&Z in this area? So
high level, what is it doing?
And then we can philtre down and
see and and do the analysis then
that makes sense. And what about
the event section?
Or the top three.
You know.
I can't say what the utility
will be at the moment because.
Mike.
The one thing I would just just
top of mind, there are so many
events that happen in in the
field of anyone therapeutic area
because that it is almost
impossible to keep track of the
the really key ones.
Umm.
So if you take just as an
example, asthma that we just
had, there's been quite a lot of
data coming out.
I don't know how you can capture
all of that, because some of it
is going to be.
Oh, this is an interesting
article, but it's not going to
change anything.
So I don't know what people are
maybe looking at if they're
looking at key events are.
OK, something is being got
registration.
So how do you philtre these
events to make sure that they
are relevant to the user here?
And I don't know how you can do
that because.
If you're gonna report, for
instance, uh checkpoint
inhibitors.
There are hundreds of trials and
every time you go in you're
going to see, you know, 50 new
trial. I'm exaggerating. Well,
maybe not. Depends how often you
go in. But let's say you see 50
new trials. It just becomes a
blur.
And it's basically loses
relevance, so I don't know how
you can.
Philtre these events um.
In a way that makes sense to the
users, but it's it's almost like
over overkill within with data
rather than information.
That makes sense, but that's the
way to track it.
But it's, I don't know how
important it is to from an
overview from an individual
product or an individual product
category.
It's it's quite useful.
Right. I want to see what's
happened with, in this case, CDK
46, which is Ibrance.
What's happened in the last X
number of months?
That's, that's helpful.
But to have it across.
Full of breast cancer when there
are a minimum of 15 major modes
of action.
It's going to be overkill. I
mean it's just data dump as far
as I can see, unless we can if
it's a way of.
Making it relevant and and
honestly I haven't thought about
how to make it relevant or
especially when you're looking
at.
Results, let's say of a phase
two trial which needs then
interpretation. OK, what does
this mean?
I think that's going into.
Yeah.
Level of analysis that.
Would be difficult.
Or your folks to actually sort
of.
Do we do this? We have a CI
department that looks at.
You know drugs coming through
for each individual therapeutic
area and within that therapeutic
area let's say and again I'll
talk my own experience in in
breast cancer. So I'll look
specifically at breast cancer
and then at the meetings we will
have, I will do a report which
will be like 50 slides, it's
crazy, but fifty slides of this
is what's in Roman and these are
this is what the impact is.
Now that's only interesting for
people in that particular area
who have relevance, but if you
take this up to senior
management, they'll go.
OK, so what's important here?
Of course, and that's and what I
would hope to get from this if
if it's possible, and I'm not
saying it is, I just think it's
really difficult is to say this
is what the impact is.
As opposed to just an event.
That's yeah. No, that's a really
interesting feedback actually.
So, uh, yeah. That's why I
wanted to ask specifically on
that, just to say, you know, if
if it is useful and if not and
if not, then how would it be
more useful. So really
interesting feedback. We'll pass
that back to the team actually,
because.
If essentially it's taking up
space on the screen where it's
not useful, or you want the
ability to choose what kind of
events you see information for,
then you know it'll probably
have more value to our users. So
really interesting feedback. The
only other thing I wanted to
mention actually was.
Just, uh, just to see whether
you use any of this kind of data
or any other sort of data, data
providers. Do you ever have a
need to see it while you're on
the go, IE remote on a mobile
phone, on a tablet?
No.
Well, simple as that well.
So I personally find that and
this is me and maybe I'm just
old fashioned. OK, so old school
I would say.
I find that uh.
The what? What do you want on a
mobile that's going to give you
specific data that I'm going to
present to my management. Well,
the answer is.
If if you can get that data on a
mobile I'm I'm not needed.
Right, because they'll have the
same access, so I needn't give
it to them.
Um and but.
What they're looking for is more
insights than the top line
numbers, OK? And I'm not sure
that you know, working on a
mobile for me is again, as I
said, I'm I'm old school. I I
find it easier to use my my
laptop to give presentations and
to sort them because at the end
what I do is I don't actually
present them.
Raw data from your reports. I
present a synthesis of it in
terms of. Here's A1 pager of.
What was what? What are the key
events?
What's happened, what are the
outcomes and what are we going
to do about it?
Makes absolute sense, um.
Yeah. No, that makes sense. Um,
OK, cool. I don't think I have
any more questions. Um, your
feedback has been extremely
helpful. So thank you. Thank you
for that. Is there any is, is
there anything else you want to
add Bernard, just generally
about the platform or any other
feedback that we've you've not
mentioned or we've not captured?
Listen, I'm very happy with what
I've got.
And I know that Ted has got more
access. I have to say I I've
only needed to ask him for a
couple of times. So that
additional access because you
know the workhorse products that
I use are are in the basic.
And once in a while, some of
those additional information
sources are are helpful.
Umm.
But I don't use the, you know.
I don't need it on hand,
basically. Yeah, cool. That's,
that's been really helpful. And
um, yeah, I know we've got a
couple of minutes, minutes left,
so you could you could have that
time back just in terms of just
in terms of an outro. What we'll
do is, and I know you're
obviously used to this because
you participated last round of
testing. We'll speak to a number
of customers. We'll then collate
all of that feedback. I'll then
summarise it in terms of what
you said and what we're going to
do about that. Um, and I'll
relay that over the next few
weeks.
Over e-mail to you as well, so
just watch out for that. What
I'd also say is you, you have
access to the platform yourself,
so the same way Magda went into
it. So if you log into the
existing platform you'll see a
little blue button. So I would
encourage you to just go in and
click around and play around for
yourself because there could be
things that you've noticed from
clicking around yourself that
you haven't while we've been
doing a screen share. So yeah, I
will follow up on e-mail anyway
so you see.
Yeah, just a little blue button
there. So you could that's how
you can access it. OK. So yeah,
have a have a look. Once you go
into there, there is a little
purple icon at the bottom left
of the screen. So if you just
click that because we've already
had a one to one. If you just
want to give short feedback and
you don't want to complete a
full survey, you can just click
give feedback and it'll just
give you an option just to put
your e-mail address and then
paste any screenshots and then
it's just an open text field. Or
if you did want to complete a
survey, there is, there is sort
of.
50 to 20 questions that are
specifically about the features.
So it's completely up to
yourself. OK sounds good. Cool.
Well I'll follow up on the
e-mail anyway so I know it's
been a bit of an information
overload, so apologies for that.
Cool. Well there. If there's
nothing else I'll close down the
call. Thank you for your time
again and I'll we hope to speak
to you on our next round of
testing. Onwards and forwards
made life continually improve.
Exactly and I hope you have a
good day and you hope you enjoy
your weekend even though we're
closer to it.
Thank you, Bernard.
Personas.
Alright, cheers. Bye, bye.